the honored walk walk walk is lon lon
gene watches have 110 World's Fair grand
prizes twenty eight gold medals and bore
honors for accuracy than any other
timepiece lon gene the world's most
honored watch is made and guaranteed by
the lawn gene with no wats company it's
time for the launching horoscope
television journal of the important
issues of the hour thought so you every
Monday Wednesday and Friday a
presentation of the lawn gene which nor
wats company maker of launching the
world's most honored watch and wit nor
distinguished companion to the world
honored lon gene good evening this is
frank night may I introduce our
co-editors for this edition of the
launching krona scope mister william
bradford huie editor of the American
mercury and mr. Henry Hazlitt editor of
The Freeman and contributing editor for
Newsweek magazine our distinguished
guest for this evening is dr. Charles
Francis potter one of America's great
philosophers liberal leader and author
of notes the opinions discuss are
necessarily those of the speakers dr.
Potter here at the beginning of the new
year ensure that our chronis coke
audience would like the views of a great
liberal preacher and you are a preacher
are you not sir and perhaps a Yankee
preacher I call me the preacher here and
you just published an autobiography
called the preacher and i right and
you've always regarded yourself you've
been a you've been a life-long liberal I
believe right and does that mean sir
that you supported new and fair deals
Truman and Roosevelt yes sir you voted
for Roosevelt throughout his career and
you voted for Truman in 48 I did well
I'm sure that our audience would like
some advice from you are like your views
tonight sir on the very grave problems
of 1952 now what do you think you
is the principal problem facing the
American people in 1952 see the problem
of morality is the leading problem it
seems to me how we can achieve a higher
and better morality as a preacher you
are concerned or as a philosopher you
are concerned about what you think is a
drift away from moral standards yes well
are you talking dr. Potter about the
morality of the American people as a
whole or the morality of the political
level of the country or what what do you
have primarily in mind morality and
government that seems to me the place
where it seems to be breaking down now
you've noted you've noted yourself a
general deterioration in government
morality I've noticed it deteriorating
but I have also noticed that we're
waking up to the fact that it is
deteriorating what strikes you is
outstanding in this what are the chief
symptoms of this breakdown morality well
lack of responsibility on the part of
men and that are high in office that
have responsible positions and even
those that are halfway down it seems to
be running like a cancer through the
whole system the whole setup you have to
vote against the present administration
in 1952 sir I certainly do and primarily
because of what you think is this moral
breakdown I do and would you say that
the tax scandals have impressed you most
as being at being most significant in
this breakdown I think that the exposure
of the scandals in the income tax
department particularly are revealing
what's happening in the whole system do
you think I don't want me there I just
want to ask is what do you think of the
main reasons for that daughter is it a
matter of the political setup or is it a
matter of a declining sense of morality
in the American public well I think that
capable honest men have stayed out of
politics when they should have been in
it and I think there is much to blame as
the crooks that are
well don't you think that in some
respects it's the immense oversized the
government has come to that's cause love
this and the immense interference of
government and the affairs of public for
example take something like the RFC now
here is an institution it's a public
bank a government bank set up for the
purpose of making loans to firms that
can't get loans from private
institutions yes now when you have such
an institution and it can make loans of
up to 100 million dollars or what not to
an individual firm doesn't this in
itself create a situation that has great
temptations not or bribery interruption
does and you think then that the
reducing of the general / unruliness of
government would help to some extent to
reduce the dimensions of the evil I
think it would reduce a temptation
somewhat but I don't think that's the
only trouble well what do these
temptations go back to you see it well
it wouldn't tempt a man unless he was
vulnerable and he's vulnerable if he
doesn't have his conscience and pretty
good working order and his conscience is
not good working order because of the
public conscience being less good
working order or because of lack of his
personal accountability well they work
together they play together the
individual says well everybody's doing
it I might as well get my share my part
and that is a cancerous thing in our
body politic that seems to me dr. Potter
I'm sure that here at the beginning of
1952 the American people want to do some
soul-searching and see where their
responsibility lies now this corruption
in government is a symptom isn't it I
mean it's a symptom of something it's
wrong with our whole people yes it's the
measles are breaking out and that's good
because now we know what the trouble is
and we can cure it I have ultimate faith
in the American people will this is only
a temporary thing and
it's only a surface thing and only if
the American people are all right when
the American people know the facts you
see the table themselves make the
correct the only danger is keeping the
facts from the people well now where
would you go back and place the blame
for this symptom that's now obvious
would you say that the a breakdown in
the home has had something to do with it
yes definitely you can trace it right
back to the home because when you begin
to blame the school the school teachers
say they haven't cooperation from the
home that when the children get to them
they haven't to any sense of moral
responsibility they destroy property in
the school even do you think has been
something you on the part of the church
well I think the church has it sir share
the blame I think the family the school
and the church all must share the blame
for some of this moral deterioration
they have to get together you don't
think that they have been teaching
perhaps enough individual responsibility
they have failed in that regard do you
think that the school should give direct
moral instruction or do you think that
ought to be left to the parents into the
church I think the school should have
morality and ethics shot through the
entire program I don't think you can
isolate them from life the whole life
must be moral and when they don't get
the cooperation of the home then when
the trouble begins they start what do
they start with they teach a child now I
lay me down to sleep I pray the Lord my
soul to keep if I should die and then
they expect the child have social
responsibility when they've focused it
upon his own welfare his own salvation
don't you think that helps to give him
some individual responsibility well to a
certain extent but the child to himself
knows he counteracts that by saying well
god bless papa god bless mommy god bless
Aunt Jane he's got a social sense there
that the prayer omits now dr. Connor I'm
sure that our audience would appreciate
some specific recommendations from you
here at the beginning of the year now
first of all what do you think in
American
do about this deteriorating situation
well I think one of the first things to
do is to excite even more the public
indignation create a more responsive of
public opinion and throw not only throw
the rascals out but to get the idea into
the people that they are themselves
responsible that they ought to go to the
polls and vote and vote intelligently
well do you think it brings a certain
public apathy among the people that they
that they can't get at an administration
except once every four years on one
specific day every four years well I
think there should be a recall provision
that would take care of that between
times with why wait four years in these
very busy times when a whole a whole
crisis can develop within a week well
you be in favor of something like the
British system in which a vote of
confidence can change in administration
overnight or a lack of vote of
confidence well I wouldn't have felt
that way once but I certainly do know
you think that the first thing the
American people to do then is to get mad
to have it to demonstrate a capacity for
moral indignation I'd like to see a wave
of righteous indignation sweep this
country but you would agree I believe
that just throwing the rascals out is
not enough all done any since it is just
a symptom why the people themselves are
going to have to produce a more
responsible branded leadership we've got
to educate our young men to appreciate
public service in public office as an
honor and a responsibility not something
to be dodged dr. Potter I'd like to ask
you what your standards would be on some
of these things for example do you think
a public official or to accept gifts
from anybody that he's in a position to
give favors to do you think we want to
accept any gifts at all or where should
he draw the line I think a person in a
public position should not accept gifts
throughout my ministry for instance I've
refused to accept a 10-percent discount
of the clergy and a half fare
the railroads because I think that's
creating a moral situation which is
dangerous and I think therefore that
anyone in a public position should be
very very careful about accepting any
gifts of any kind from anybody well as a
final question dr. Carter how would you
summarize your advice to the American
people in 1952 as to what they can do
about this situation well I'd say first
of all educate yourself on public
affairs second be sure to vote and third
be sure your own house is in order and
when the voting time comes be there and
ready to elect somebody who will be
responsible well thank you very much for
being with it to see me the editorial
board for this edition of the
non-synchronous cope was mr. Henry
Hazlitt and mr. william bradford huie
our distinguished guest was dr. charles
francis potter noted philosopher and
author